[MUSIC PLAYING]
LARRY P. ARNN: The problem
with education today
is that it's abandoned
the ground of education.
Students today are taught
that the truth is according
to the perspective of one,
that things in history
are not fixed--
that because we see
them differently,
they are different.
DAVID DIENER: Most
education today
assumes that the student
is the starting point.
KENNETH CALVERT: There's a
great deal of self-centeredness.
There's a lack of civility,
a lot of shouting,
and a lack of real
thoughtful interaction.
LARRY P. ARNN: So that
means the only thing
wrong with education today is
that it's lost its mission.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID DIENER: I've
become convinced
that one of the greatest ways
that I can impact the future
is by investing in
classical education
and helping to
cultivate students
into men and women
who are able to live
virtuous and wise lives.
KENNETH CALVERT: The
classical model is not dead.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID DIENER: At
Hillsdale Academy,
our motto is
[SPEAKING LATIN],, which
is Latin for virtue and wisdom.
And that really is the
backbone of what we do here.
And it's really the backbone of
what a classical education is
all about.
KATHLEEN O'TOOLE:
In America today,
I think we often
think of education
as training for a
particular career
or a particular course of life.
A classical education is
more well-rounded than that,
and it remembers that,
no matter who you are,
there's a moral
education, a character
education, a civic education.
DAVID DIENER: And
so, what we're doing
in the classical
education tradition is,
we are drawing on the
wisdom of the ages.
We are exposing our
students to the wisdom
that has gone before.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So we don't get
to make up truth.
Just as there are laws that
govern the physical universe,
there are also moral laws.
ELIZABETH SCHLUETER: One of
the challenges of education
is forming virtue
in its students.
And this is something
the Academy excels at.
ELIZABETH GRZESIAK:
Things like fortitude,
perseverance, prudence--
these good virtues are tested
at school on a daily basis.
I learned the importance
of responsibility
and being able to take care
of the people around me.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID DIENER: From
Plato's Academy onward,
over the centuries, learning
has happened in community.
And what we have at
Hillsdale Academy
is a community of learners.
Our students, our teachers,
our staff-- everyone
working together to promote
the cultivation of virtue
and wisdom in our students.
NATHAN SCHLUETER:
Our daughter, Helen--
in a given semester, she's
learning Shakespearean drama,
competed in cross country,
played violin in the orchestra.
This was not a girl
that was stressed out
about filling up a
resume with activities
that she could burnish a resume
with to get into their college.
She wanted to-- she was
just loving her friendships
and all of these things.
And I just see that
and think, wow.
RACHEL CUTHBERT: It
has truly been a joy
to watch our children
learn to love to learn.
NATHAN SCHLUETER:
There hardly is
a day that goes
by that we are not
looking at each other with a
kind of giddiness of gratitude
for having the Academy here.
DEANNA DUCHER: For
this tiny school
that has had 303 graduates
for 21 years straight,
we had at least one student
in the national merit program.
There was one year
that hit a class--
I think, of '19, we had five
national merit finalists.
NOLAN SULLIVAN: I had
three different teachers
in high school who have their
PhD, which, I feel like,
is very rare.
MICHAEL ROBERTS:
This is not a place
that teachers pass through.
It's a destination.
It's where they want to stay.
It's where they want
to build their career,
put down their roots, and
really invest long-term
in Hillsdale Academy,
in Hillsdale College,
and in their students.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
KENNETH CALVERT: It's
not an elite school.
It's not a prep school.
What it is is a school
that holds the bar high so
that we can produce the
best sorts of citizens
that our country needs.
ELIZABETH GRZESIAK:
So it's not just
about our little
school in Hillsdale.
Suddenly, it's quite big.
This is for the
sake of our nation,
for the sake of just
government and self governance.
Everything that our
country was founded on.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID DIENER: As
Hillsdale College's work
in K-12 classical education
continues to expand,
the Academy will continue
to play an incredibly
important role in that mission.
We want to continue
growing as a school,
becoming better at the
education we provide,
continuing to expand
our facilities to meet
the needs of our student
enrollment growth
so that we can better serve the
mission of Hillsdale College--
and serve our country--
as a model of what classical
education can and should be.
LARRY P. ARNN: The Academy
is an excellent thing.
And it needs to be.
And so, for it to be
an excellent thing,
it needs to be funded
to a sufficient level.
Education for the young--
it's for people who are
not making a living yet.
Somebody has to help them.
And so, that partnership between
the people who support it
and the people who carry
on its activity, that's
natural and necessary.
KATHLEEN O'TOOLE: By
supporting Hillsdale Academy,
you are helping
Hillsdale College teach K
through 12 schools
across the country
what a beautiful classical
education looks like
and how education in this
country ought to be done.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID DIENER: We're not
in this to make money.
We are in this to
serve the students who
walk the halls of our buildings,
to bless their families--
but also, to bless
and contribute
to our nation and the world.
ELIZABETH SCHLUETER: We are
very aware that the donors have
supported that education
for our families.
ELIZABETH GRZESIAK: I
was sponsored myself
by a woman in
Florida who decided
that classical
education was important.
Because of Mrs. McCullom, I
was able to go to high school.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NOLAN SULLIVAN: Through coaching
basketball, coaching soccer,
and doing tutoring, I've
still kept a connection
to the school.
And I think what
keeps drawing me back
is, I've started to realize
more and more what Hillsdale
Academy has given to me
and how much of an impact
Hillsdale Academy
has had on my life.
DAVID DIENER: The reach
that Hillsdale Academy
has had across our nation
and the educational impact
is enormous.
NATHAN SCHLUETER:
It's got a mission
to prepare citizens
to be entrepreneurs
and to raise families and to
help with other organizations.
Because that's the
backbone of a free society.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID DIENER: I can
think of no better way
to invest in the future
than by investing
in the classical education
of our young men and women.
What classical schools like
Hillsdale Academy are doing
is cultivating students so
that they can live well and so
that they can pass
on what they have
learned to future generations.
A classical Christian education
is an investment in eternity.
[MUSIC PLAYING]